sure isn't  it is definitely not a losing battle  once a losing battle is companies  treat their employees  that's why people leave  of course there's new options and  there's incredible things going on the  gig economy influencers like  like solopreneur there's so much  incredible stuff but you can have  tremendous retention  how about giving a [ __ ] about your  employees how about actually caring  about what they care about how about  actually trying to be human  what's a losing battle is companies  acting like they did the last 70 years  and not giving any [ __ ]  bottom line  for a p l  what's not a losing battle is if the new  generation of emotionally intelligent  leaders lead their organizations by both  caring about the business and their  employees it's possible you can do both  and then everyone can win